on va se faire un petit détecteur de
mensonges avec pâques on a une nouvelle
machine qui vient des états unis mais
seulement toujours à la voix elle va
savoir si tu mens ou pas on va pouvoir
se poser des questions tour à tour j'ai
vu ça nous concerne on attention c'est
parti c'est le détecteur de morceaux
très libre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
patrick je vais te poser la première
question tu vas devoir répondre en toute
franchise et bien sûr le détecteur dira
si c'est vrai ou si c'est fou entre nous
partir yc mauguio patrick tu répond par
oui ou par non ouais entre nous patrick
as tu écris le petit bonhomme en mousse
en pensant à fabien lecoeuvre non syrie
on pense à ta table
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je
[Applaudissements]
j'en sais rien
c'était le cheval hotte était l'otage
mais c'est vrai mais descendre ses voix
6 décembre 1998 c'était premier plan à
pareille date de maman déjà que je me
prépare
j'essaie à chaque sac thouaré attention
il peut la sortir la gaffe quand même
patrick tu peux me pose des questions
entre nous ah si tu avais vu ouf
avant or aurais-tu engagé ce merveilleux
mathieu de l'amp
oui c'est mais une phrase oui comme
avait dit mon ami fogiel et sa demie de
participation on peut découvrir le
talent d'une personne même dans une
mauvaise émission exacto oui c'est vrai
et on peut découvrir le nom talent d'une
personne même dans une bonne émission et
c'est vachement profonde et à vue bah
oui tout est profond avec mathieu
voici la question entre nous patrick on
m'a dit que j'allais partir en vacances
avec delphine ernotte la patronne de
france télévisions c'est vrai ça c'est
une fille pas eu la chambre donc oui non
non non on n'a pas d'argent on a compris
pourquoi on sait que c'est vrai je pars
pas raccord avec n'ont jamais en
vacances
tiens ce que je me retiens de dire c'est
terrible je sais pas je peux pas tu peux
me poser une question oui entre nous
qu'est ce que tu me parles de delphine
ernotte
cyril on va dit que ça allait partir en
vacances avec ara aprikian pas été
capables si gentil satom moi j'aime bien
tu sais que tu l'aies de merde non
c'est partir en vacances et que non
pourquoi ouais bah je peux pas ici bas
je sais pas parce que je vais voir mais
je crois qu'il m'a pas invité
bon sang mais peut-être non peut-être
voilà peut-être si tu viens on peut
faire une barque avec là que ça se passe
mieux avec lui on est de re devenu on se
parle je suis né dedans moi tu sais mais
normalement cyril je suis plus là dedans
du tout bon c'est fini tout ça c'est
derrière moi totalement car elles
atterrissent fille ab je peux te dire je
veux plus jamais de ma vie je serai
animateurs divertissement et ses essais
je vais vous dire
et quelque part c'est bien parce que je
vais rester j'ai eu du temps pour
réfléchir à ça je suis resté dans la
mémoire des gens et la mémoire elle
améliore toujours bien les choses
moi j'ai vécu des années formidables je
suis plus du tout envie je me suis fait
jeter comme un chien je vais pas revenir
à lécher les moufles de ce qu'ils
mangent c'est comme un chien danger de
langage en plus cher ici la direction de
france inchangée qui te rappelle non non
non je sais plus je vais dire pourquoi
en plus parce que toi tu es bien placé
pour le savoir quand on fait de la télé
comme j'en faisais tu te fais démonté
sans arrêt par déjà surtout des mecs qui
regarde tu dis sont masochistes les mecs
parce qu'il ya une télécommande sont
probables regarder pour l'heure ils sont
cons et ou alors il juste sans regarder
et là je suis sur scène pratiquement
tous les soirs j'ai des gens qui
m'aiment et que j'aime c'est vachement
agréable
il n'y a que ceux qui t'aiment qui
viennent te voir alors je suis désolé
pour ceux qui nous aimaient bien parce
qu'il y en a qui nous aiment et rappelé
mais pour moi je suis dix fois plus
heureux avec des gens bienveillants home
a interdit de faire ça je le faire sur
scène d'ailleurs ça va peut-être faire
plaisir aux gens qui nous regardent en
on va ouvrir les locations là bientôt
mi-décembre en décembre prochain
on part faire le plus grand cabaret du
monde dans tous les zéniths en france ça
c'est un scoop c'est normal
[Applaudissements]
tout ce qu'on a
qu'est ce qu'on nous a empêché de faire
à la télé on va aller le faire en vrai
c'est nord les gens va mettre 12 12 14
numéro un et je pense que cela fera
plaisir ça va être sympa et vous avez
dit que j'aurai au moins j'aurai j'aurai
un public qui va venir parce qu'ils
aiment ça qu'ils sont gentils se jure
c'est une autre ville je suis pas ça
m'embête pour plein de choses sous
l'angle est financièrement mais ça c'est
pas important pour tous les exporter et
kibaki du travail et ouais pour
m'essayer puis pour tous les gens qui
aiment et ce à quoi qu'on a pris tout ça
parce qu'on aurait peut-être pu faire
une 2e c'est patrick jeudy ou à essayer
de garder le maximum de ses équipes et
autour d'eux mais j'en ai mais après il
ya d'autres trucs aussi sur youtube on
peut faire plein de choses il ya
d'autres moyens de communication jean
écarté c'est chez nous il ya la scène
c'est pas exclu que sur youtube je fasse
des trucs mais en tant qu'animateur
immanente divertissement la télé non
j'ai donné animateur je vais faire ce
que j'ai pu j'ai essayé de faire du
mieux que je pouvais on a on a essayé de
donner du bonheur aux gens
j'ai plutôt envie en plus parce que là
je n'ai plus envie
j'ai 36 balais et j'ai envie de
continuer à m'éclater comme je vais être
franchement est-ce que j'ai l'impression
d'aller mal je me suis jamais senti
aussi bien
alors oui ça m'a fait plaisir de sortir
de sa gêne guirado d entre nous patrick
est ce que tu pourrais être candidat au
poste de président à france télévisions
absolument mais absolument pas c'est
plus mon monde ça c'est pas mon monde du
tout finie c'est non non c'est pas mon
monde du tout je suis choyé appuis je te
dis je pas me plaindre j'ai fait trente
piges
mais tant de bonheur avec des choses
assez bien scellier et je discute avec
des mômes aujourd'hui que je croise qui
ont 25 ans 30 ans qui nice à [ __ ]
c'est pas mal finalement tu as grandi
avec ça un bain au moins dans la mémoire
des mômes on est on est on est des
locaux et voilà tu as une question posée
oui vainqueur on bouffe est ce que tu as
déjà ah oui elle est belle celle là est
ce que tu as déjà regardé une seule fois
c'est que de la télé du début à la fin
avec valérie benaïm wii ne peut pas papa
papa et non sa part et de quoi
aujourd'hui
alors j'ai pas puis j'avais pas d'accord
j'avais énormément d'amour je suis
regardé et valérie qui parler j'adore
j'adore cette émission calorique entre
nous est-ce que tu va regarder la soirée
du réveillon sur france 2 bah non je
regardais déjà pas parce que je la
faisais tu m'as h à caunes et ses
partenaires
non je vais être en face à d'accord rien
je vais peut-être c'était un oeil je
vais passer le relais avec des amis j'ai
peut-être je vais sera sur tf1
ouais je fais ils m'ont invité c'est un
musée trop j'ai participé aux bêtisiers
je participe aux bêtises il repasse
plein que ils m'ont même retrouver une
image où je fais un strip tease chez
dechavanne
non je vais passer une demi heure avec
eux c'est très sympa ou l'enregistrer et
non je reviendrai pas en plus est par
contre j ai rien contre ces mes copines
danyellah m'a appelé la productrice m'a
appelée elle te produis et sur l'a1
moment sûr quand on faisait la fête de
la musique en est quand elle a décidé de
faire le truc 31 elle m'a appelé
faustine m'a appelé en me disant patrick
on apprend dans ta place mais
franchement sophie le symbôle daft et
non je la connais pas la nature mais
j'ai rien contre elle non tant mieux
c'est la vie qui continue c'est des
chansons c'est moi je vais être autre
chose et puis moi je vais être avec mes
potes le 31 décembre tu as bien fait tu
as une question de poser dessus et j'en
ai vu encore faut-il que comme tu veux
bah oui oui oui
ah mais moi j'ai la réponse est ce que
tu penses être le meilleur animateur du
paf un nom moteur moins puissant te
cirer les pompes théâtre et bateleurs tu
sers un jour je sais plus qui ma vie je
crois que c'est guy lux qui m'avait dit
un bon animateur c'est un mec est
capable de vendre les camemberts doivent
au supermarché à n'importe qui je crois
que tu es capable de le faire ça tu vas
dans sérieusement merci entre ces
bateleur c'est il ya présentateurs et
animateurs animateur s'est donné une âme
critiquable aux besoins mais tu as donné
une âme à tous salle à tous ces gens jeu
va merci aux actions voyez je vais dire
secrétaire anti tht envoyé un mot il ya
un mois j'avais fait une déconne tous
ensemble avec vos histoires d'un mois de
chemin clac et devant la télé et je sais
ni cyril c'est ça que les gens rient
encore plus à la déconne à moi j'aimais
bien quand c'était une cour de récré
c'est ce qu'ont fait donc je vais poser
mon pantalon
bon je sais mon passé merci